in the Goonies it was Sean Astin's first
movie Josh Brolin's first movie chef
Cohen's first movie in Carrie greens
first movie so all of those kids and
mine and yours yes so what was it like
working with Mike we talked a little bit
upstairs about it and working on these
films he was short you were tall you've
covered it pretty well
but how did the kid process because
that's a really delicate thing we do I
mean with these jewels I must say Steven
and and Mike had really had a lot to do
with Steven love kids I hate kids
well I I think he'd get bored by them
why don't we take a look at a couple of
clips of the kids that you don't like
very much each one of each one of those
kids was so memorable but also you had
robert davi
Joey pants and Anne ran into him and
Anne Ramsey and that was before throw
mama from the Train
yeah she was fantastic they are or he
wasn't a misfit in the operation
actually they were all misfits they were
all misfits but they they're so
memorable or each one of those children
are so unique and so individual and all
of them went on to work no no no Carrie
Carrie married children but she came
back she came back
well one of the things that happened is
is with dick dick was so open to the
children he may not have liked him but
he was certainly open I love them I love
them I know you love him and he made
great decisions and it made it a
wonderful event we have stayed close to
him all these years
yeah they're my kids it's an Lawrence
but I mean they all turned out to be
amazing the interesting thing is you
would read them they bring him into the
office and you've read him and kind of
honing it down to a group and we'd read
them together and and finally it was it
it was and then the first day of
shooting they everybody they they were
hidden their characters but they were
they had become little actors I don't
know although non-professionals but they
they were working on each other and they
finished a scene and something was so
flat then I thought back to our casting
when we were doing it where we were
treating the lines have and I'm jumping
em and he's having me and Stevens on top
of us all and I and I listen to the kids
they were all sitting in their little
chairs we yapping on top of each other
knowing of the you know word in edgewise
so I realized what it was we what we had
working in the readings was not working
on the stage because they were afraid to
overlap each other I'm talking over each
other they would wait for the other two
cue each other and then say their lines
and it was not children well it became a
little so I said just be who you are be
what you're doing then I'll be what you
did when we read it and they started to
read on top of each other and couldn't
shut up and it was wonderful I mean the
editor was gonna kill me because it's
very difficult to put together but this
that was a picture could have been the
most difficult picture in the world and
it turned out to be one of the most
wonderful ones ever worked on
and that certainly was memorable